[Music]
one of the big gifts this christmas is
the kindle fire which is uh amazon's
answer to the ipad
you know they came out with uh the
kindle fire but a lot of customers are
complaining about a bunch of problems
they experience with the kindle fire and
just a couple of hours ago the company
released this message
to reassure their customers
[Music]
hi i'm amazon ceo jeff bezos
as far as you know
i'm here to reassure you that we here at
amazon have listened to all your
complaints about our new kindle fire and
we've got it all well in hand for
example some of you said it was too easy
to accidentally turn off well
not anymore
what about those concerned about our
security signal every time you check the
web
let me tell you we are definitely
looking into that then there's the
kindle fires occasional tendency to do
this
ironic no
well we've got an easy fix for that
introducing the kindle firebox just drop
your kindle in
and seal the lid
until no oxygen can get in
problem solved
and if all else fails there's our brand
new one push solution button right here
at the bottom
so happy holidays and many happy returns
to amazon
free of charge
[Applause]